DANA PERINO AND TOM SHILLUE.
IT’S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
ONLY SEVEN HOURS LEFT TO PREVENT
ANOTHER GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
THE DEADLINE IS MIDNIGHT.
WE ARE WAITING AN UPCOMING VOTE
ON THE SPENDING FELL BY THE
SENATE.
IT’S EXPECTED TO PASS THERE BUT
UNCERTAIN IN THE HOUSE.
DEMOCRATS ONCE AGAIN STALLING OF
BUDGET TO FORCE A FIX OVER
DREAMERS.
NANCY PELOSI PULLS A DRAMATIC
STUNT YESTERDAY, RECORD-SETTING
EIGHT HOURS SPEECH ON THE FLOOR.
>> WE HAVE THE FIRST REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT IN MODERN TIMES, THE
FIRST PRESIDENT REALLY WHO IS
ANTI-IMMIGRANT.
WE ARE NOT ASKING FOR SOMETHING
OFF THE WALL.
IT’S SOMETHING, YEAH, MAYBE IT
IS OFF-THE-WALL.
MAYBE THE WALL IS THE ISSUE.
THE REPUBLICANS MORAL COWARDICE
MUST END.
I THOUGHT MAYBE WE SHOULD PRAY
ALL DAY ON THE FLOOR OF
CONGRESS.
MAYBE I SHOULD BRING MY ROSARY
BLESSED BY THE POPE.
>> Jesse: DID IT YIELD
RESULTS?
EVEN DEMOCRATS AREN’T HAPPY WITH
THE MINORITY LEADER’S
PERFORMANCE.
ONE OF HER COLLEAGUES FELL
ASLEEP.
ANOTHER UNNAMED LIBERAL TELLS
POLITICAL "THIS HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH PROTECTING VULNERABLE
MAMMALS TRICKLE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
TO TAKE A DIFFICULT VOTE."
>> I’M HAPPY SHE IS STEPPING UP.
I HOPE SHE KEEPS A FIGHT GOING.
SPEECHES ARE GREAT.
THEY ARE GOOD, IMPORTANT AND I’M
THANKFUL FOR THE SPEECH BUT MORE
IMPORTANT IS TO MAINTAIN YOUR
PRINCIPLES, MAINTAIN YOUR
POLITICAL PRINCIPLES.
>> Jesse: THIS HAS BEEN SAID
MANY TIMES BEFORE, KIMBERLY.
NANCY PELOSI HAS NEVER STOOD UP
THAT LONG FOR VETERANS, POLICE
OFFICERS, FACTORY WORKERS,
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO ILLEGALS,
THERE FOR EIGHT HOURS.
>> Kimberly: FOR RELIGIOUS
FREEDOM.
>> Jesse: OR ANYTHING.
>> Kimberly: EXACTLY.
GOES TO SHOW WHERE HER MIND-SET
IS.
POLITICS AND IDEOLOGY.
THE PROBLEM IS SHE COMES OFF AS
NOT BEING VERY GENUINE, COMES
OFFICE OF POLITICAL CIRCUS,
THEATRICAL.
YOU LOSE CREDIBILITY WHEN YOU DO
THINGS LIKE THIS.
SHE’S HAD THIS REPUTATION FOR
QUITE SOME TIME.
THE DISTRICT IN SAN FRANCISCO.
>> Jesse: GERALDO, REPUBLICANS
WANT THIS.
THEY SAY THEY WANT TO SAY MORE
PELOSI.
GREAT ADVERTISEMENT.
FACE OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
SHE IS THE GIFT THAT KEEPS ON
GIVING.
>> Geraldo: IT WAS AN
IMPRESSIVE PHYSICAL PERFORMANCE.
OUTLASTED ALL THE GUYS.
SHE DID IN HIGH HEELS.
LIKE GINGER ROGERS.
SHE DID THIS SAME THING AS FRED
ASTAIRE ONLY DANCING BACKWARDS
AND HIGH HEELS.
>> Jesse: HOW DO YOU KNOW
RAND PAUL WASN’T WEARING HIGH
HEELS?
YOU DON’T KNOW THAT.
>> Geraldo: FOR ME TO COUPLE
THE BUDGETARY PROCESS WITH THE
DREAMER’S PLIGHT IS A TERRIBLE
SERVICE.
DISSERVICE TO THE DREAMERS, TO
MAKE THEM THE ISSUE, THE
INFLAMMATORY ISSUE.
IMMIGRATION RAISES THE HACKLES
OF PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES.
TO MAKE THAT THE HEADLINE FOR
THE DEMOCRATS POINT OF VIEW ON
THE BUDGETARY PROCESS IS SO
UNFAIR AND SO COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
I THINK -- I ONLY WISH I WAS IN
CHARGE, GETTING THE DREAMERS
THEIR FUTURE SECURE.
I THINK NANCY PELOSI DID
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO GET THERE.
>> Jesse: A LOT OF PEOPLE
BELIEVE THAT.
YOU ARE AT THE BARGAINING TABLE.
YOU SAID IT WAS A GOOD BILL AND
THEN YOU SAY YOU’RE VOTING
AGAINST IT.
>> Dana: I AM TRYING TO PUT
MYSELF IN MORE OF A PROGRESSIVE
OR A DREAMERS SHOE, HIGH HEELS
EVEN.
LOOKING AT IT FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE.
NANCY PELOSI HAS BEEN UNDER THE
GUN FOR A LOT OF DIFFERENT
REASONS.
SHE IS PUBLIC ENEMY NUMBER ONE
FOR REPUBLICANS AND ALSO THERE
IS AN INTERGENERATIONAL
DISCUSSION GOING ON WITH THE
DEMOCRATS.
AT 77, SOME SAY SHE NEEDS TO
MOVE ON.
SHE SHOWED THEM I HAVE MORE
STAMINA THAN ALL OF YOU.
I WILL STAND HERE FOR EIGHT
HOURS AND TALK ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
MAYBE IT DOESN’T ADVANCE THE
BALL LEGISLATIVELY BUT PERHAPS
FOR HER POLITICALLY IT DOES HELP
HER IN THE MIDTERMS WITH THAT
SECTION OF HER BASE.
>> Jesse: PRETTY IMPRESSIVE.
EIGHT HOURS.
TOM, HAVE YOU EVER DONE ANYTHING
FOR EIGHT HOURS STRAIGHT?
>> Tom: EIGHT HOURS, EVERY
DAY, THAT’S ALL WE DO.
I SAW "MR. SMITH GOES TO
WASHINGTON."
HE WAS THERE FOR TWO DAYS.
TED CRUZ 221 HOURS AND EVERYBODY
MADE FUN OF HIM.
-- DID 22 HOURS.
>> Jesse: WE’VE HAD THAT
SCHUMER SHUT DOWN, PELOSI
MARATHON SPEECH.
BOYCOTTING THE INAUGURATION.
IS THERE SOMETHING ELSE BESIDES
STUNT THAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE?
>> Kimberly: EVERY DAY IT IS
LIKE RIPLEY’S BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO NEXT?
ONE OF A GETTING DONE?
HOW ABOUT HELPING PEOPLE AND
COMING TO THE TABLE AND WORKING
COOPERATIVELY.
I SAY THIS FOR BOTH SIDES THAT
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO DO IT.
WE HAVE TO CALL IT OUT RIGHT NO
NOW.
WE CALL IT WHEN WE SEE IT FROM
THE OTHER SIDE.
LET’S GET SOME TRACTION AND TRY
TO DO SOMETHING.
YOU YOUR EIGHT HOURS ARE BETTER
SPENT AT THE TABLE WITH MEMBERS
OF THE OTHER PARTY OR PRESIDENT
TRYING TO WORK ON SOMETHING.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF
THIS DOG AND PONY SHOW.
THE PELOSI PONY SHOW.
HEELS.
COME ON.
ENOUGH ALREADY.
>> Dana: TED CRUZ TOO.
DEMOCRATS SAID THIS IS A STUNT
THAT WILL GET YOU NOTHING.
ELECTIONS ARE THE BEST REVENGE.
THE ONLY THING YOU CAN DO TO GET
PRESS IN THE MINORITY IS TO DO A
STUNT THAT WILL HELP YOU.
THEY DON’T CARE THEY ARE NOT
GETTING GOOD PRESS HERE.
THEY ARE GETTING GOOD PRESS IN
THEIR HOME DISTRICTS.
RAISING MORE MONEY THAN
REPUBLICANS SO FAR.
I THINK THAT COULD CHANGE AFTER
Q1.
FOR RIGHT NOW, THE BEST THING
THEY CAN DO IS GET ENOUGH PRESS
IN THEIR DISTRICTS.
RAISE THE KIND OF MONEY AND TRY
TO WIN THE ELECTION.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE NOT RAISING
A LOT OF MONEY.
THEIR DEBT ON THE DNC SIDE.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF BILLS TO PAY.
THE MEDIA IS NOT TALKING ABOUT
THE SPLIT IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THEY LOVE TO COVER THE SPLITS IN
THE REPUBLICAN SIDE.
THE SPLIT ON THE LEFT OVER THIS
ISSUE.
>> Geraldo: I DON’T KNOW THAT
THERE IS A DEMOCRATIC PARTY
ANYMORE.
GOING BACK TO WHAT KIMBERLY
SAID, HOW IMPRESSIVE, HOW
SURPRISINGLY OPTIMISTIC WAS IT
YESTERDAY.
WE SAW MITCH MCCONNELL AGREEING
WITH CHUCK SCHUMER TO GO FORWARD
ON A TWO-YEAR BUDGET DEAL.
TWO YEARS.
NOT 10 MINUTES, NOT TWO DAYS.
TWO-YEAR BUDGET DEAL.
MAJORITY LEADER, MINORITY
LEADERS STANDING ONE AFTER THE
OTHER.
MY COLLEAGUE, MY COLLEAGUE.
THAT’S THE WAY IT IS SUPPOSED TO
WORK AND TODAY WE’RE BACK TO
THIS AGAIN.
>> Kimberly: IT IS A MIRAGE.
>> Jesse: ANY LAST WORDS, TOM.
>> Tom: I THINK -- CAN THEN GO
PAST MIDNIGHT, CAN THEY DO AN